sehr geehrte damen und herren ich
begrüße sie herzlich zum pressegespräch
mit einzelne strecken sehr geehrte damen
und herren war für uns alle
insbesondere aber für das gesamte bisher
ein herausforderndes tja und so den
verschiedensten einflüsse so gefordert
wie schon lange nicht wenn ich nur die
flächen deckenden testungen der
migrations einsatz aber spaß einzeln
oder auch anders und tracing denke dass
das möglich war dass weitere besondere
weil wir es wert bundesheer mit grund
wird ihnen schnell und gut organisierte
männer nach dass wir kunden und so war
es möglich dass im heurigen jahr allein
im heurigen jahr unglaubliche 229 1837
personen tage im einsatz von dem bundes
von den grundlagen des bundesheeres
geleistet wurden um die selbst also zu
verdeutlichen
ein einzelner wäre dann heißt das er bei
6 130 jahre gearbeitet von assistenz
einsätzen über katastropheneinsätze bis
hin zur unterstützungsleistung unsere
grundwehrdiener waren immer zur stelle
und daher ist es mir ein persönliches
bedürfnis an dieser stelle daher zu
sagen vielen dank
sehr geehrte damen und herren im alltag
einer ministerium gibt es projekte die
binnen weniger tage umgesetzt werden und
es gibt projekte die brauchen ob ihre
sensibilität oder auch ihre komplexität
durchaus auf einige monate ja so freue
ich mich heute hier stehen zu dürfen
gemeinsam war mit frau ministerin
köstinger und ihnen über die
fortschritte im bereich der tauglichkeit
berichten zu dürfen
als ich immer sind und länder anfang
einer dieses in diesem
haushaltsministerin eingezogen bin
glaube ich endlich angehörige eines
ressorts gefragt was werden denn die
größten herausforderungen sein die wir
so als bundesheer in den nächsten jahren
zu bewältigen haben und
überdurchschnittlich oft
überdurchschnittlich oft ist die antwort
dann kommen wir werden als zu wenige gut
haben den bekommen auf der sehr
schwachen jahrgänge zu und immer mehr
männer schaffen die testung nicht mehr
jeder vierte in manchen regionen sogar
jeder dritte junge mann ist nicht
tauglich und vor dieser herausforderung
stehen haben wir mit dem
regierungsprogramm im gepäck die antwort
haus arbeiten können die tauglichkeit
das heißt wir arbeiten seit einem jahr
die experten das verteidigungsressort in
abstimmung mit dem erwartet an diesem
projekt geführt dadurch an general
harald modus sekte erinnern auch dann
für detailfragen zur verfügung stehen
wird immer hart an dieser stelle vielen
vielen dank für dieses perfekt
umgesetzte projekt ja absatz der
projektarbeit hat das ungefähr und die
bevölkerung viele male gesehen wie
wichtig unsere grundwerte ihnen sind ich
denke an die tausenden grund wird ihnen
tausende stunden im kampf gegen das
corona wie rosberg & tracing grenze von
festen und so weiter geleistet haben bzw
leisten in diesen stunden an dieser
stelle
als dankeschön an alle gruppen und
gefreiten die in ihren grundwehrdienst
für österreich da waren bzw es jetzt
noch sind ja nun zur tauglichkeit oder
lassen sie es mich so formulieren dem
grundwehrdienst nach maß beginnend mit
einem gemeinsamen ministerrat beschloss
im frühjahr bei dem wir uns auch
bundesregierung dazu entschieden haben
auf die traurigkeit zu setzen hat das
experten-team insgesamten neuen
arbeitsgruppen die umsetzung datei
traurigkeit ausgearbeitet und der ball
wurde festgestellt dass dieses ressort
intern so wie in der vergangenheit auch
per erlass umsetzen ist konkret wurde es
geschafft die täglichen im rahmen der
bestehenden tauglichkeitsstufen zu
subsumieren und umzusetzen das heißt das
konkret wird die männer die altbekannten
neuen tauglichkeitsstufen geben die
jedoch mit neuen kriterien behaftet sind
konkret wird der junge mann bei seiner
stellung danach beurteilt werden für
welche bereiche er tauglich ist und für
welche nicht wie gesagt der
grundwehrdienst nach maß um ein beispiel
zu nennen der sportlicher junger mann
und eine schulterverletzung
der bestatter nicht einberufen
der wird nun tauglich sein leben nur für
den bereich des schiffes mit dem
sturmgewehr dein spiel nicht weil er das
gewehr seine in einer seiner verletzung
schuld wäre nicht anschlagen könnte sehr
wohl aber keiner im einsatz sein als für
kraftfahrer wie wir ja so dringend
gebraucht hat mit den logistischen
bereich das heißt aber auch nicht dass
er nicht lernt sich mit einer anderen
waffe zu verteidigen
denken sie nur an dem fest der jetzt
insbesondere auch für den migrations
einsatz an den grenzen
auch da das auto fand sie sehen die
thematik wird in jedem fall eines wird
nach maß ausgerichtet sie wird ohne
zweifel individueller das heißt für
jeden grund wird li na wird 1 und
entschieden werden was er körperlich und
psychisch kann und was eben nicht tun
kann
nach diesen kriterien wird eben dieser
ganz persönliche und fertigungs
verbraucher gestaltet werden und
wirklich untauglich werden nur noch
männer seien für die der grundwehrdienst
psychisch oder physisch wirklich nicht
möglich ist und damit ermöglichen wir
beinahe jeden männlichen staatsbürger
seinen beitrag für österreich im rahmen
des grundwehrdienstes oder eben des
zivildienstes zu leisten
wann treten diese regelungen kraft diese
regelungen treten
die von beginn an geplant ab dem
geburten jahr 2003 in kraft wie jener
partie aufgrund der korona krise im jahr
2020 nicht getestet worden sind werden
selbstverständlich noch nach dem alten
recht untersucht das heißt somit
beginnende stellungspflichtigen des
jahrgangs 2003 voraussichtlich im märz
ich darf dankeschön sagen
bundesministerin der generalmajor
stellvertretend für alle altersgruppen
mitgearbeitet haben für diesen ganz
besonderen schritt unseren dienst nach
maß vielen dank geschätzter monaten sehr
geehrte frau verteidigungsministerin das
jahr 2020 war für uns alle wirklich eine
besonders große herausforderung das hat
auch uns im zivildienst außerordentlich
betroffen
ich habe ja mit dem letzten
bundesministerien gesetz die
zuständigkeit für den zivildienst damit
auch die zivilen serviceagentur wo die
zuständigkeit vom bmi also vom
innenministerium dieses
bundesministerium für landwirtschaft
regionen und tourismus bekommen wir
haben am 10 märz einen zivildienst
gipfel veranstaltet mit allen wichtigen
trägerorganisationen bezahlen der
zivilgesellschaft mit der zivilist
serviceagentur darüber beraten was es an
anpassungen für den zivildienst in den
nächsten jahren auch braucht auch dort
ist das thema e10 tauglichkeit
intensiv angesprochen worden
gleichzeitig war unserem team im märz
noch nicht bewusst dass wir wenige tage
später erstmals in der zweiten republik
einen ausserordentlichen zivildienst
ausrufen werden müssen
ich glaube dass speziell des bundesheer
aber auch der zivildienst in den letzten
monaten eindrucksvoll bewiesen haben
dass die einrichtungen die institutionen
ganz wichtiges sicherheitsnetz für
unsere bürgerinnen und bürger in
österreich darstellen dass man sich auf
das bundesheer genauso wie auf den
zivildienst in jeder lage auch verlassen
kann und vor allem wenn es auch zu einer
krise kommt da sehen genau jene menschen
auch für bevölkerung dar
ob ordentlich oder ausserordentlicher
zivildiener alle haben in diesem jahr
einen wirklich besonderen beitrag
geleistet dafür möchte ich mich wirklich
ausdrücklich bedanken
vor allem banken davon bei den rund 4500
ausserordentlichen zivildiener die ihn
früher des heurigen jahres
die spezielle form einer betroffenen
gesundheitseinrichtungen maßgeblich
verstärkt und unterstützt haben sie
waren teil einer absoluten premiere wir
haben innerhalb weniger tage auch eine
entsprechende gesetzesnovelle veranlasst
um eben diesen ausserordentlichen
zivildienst zum ersten mal in der
zweiten republik auch abhalten zu können
und ausrufen zu können
die situation war durchaus
besorgniserregend wir waren in den
ersten wochen der korona pandemie in
europa wir haben die bilder aus italien
und spanien gesehen wie das
gesundheitssystem teilweise kollabiert
sind
und für uns als gesamte bundes
region war klar so etwas darf in
österreich nicht passieren
unser ziel war es leben zu schützen vor
allem auch leben zu retten und es uns
auch mit unterstützung des
ausserordentlichen zivildienstes
gelungen
der zivilist hat damit für uns vor allem
auch seine bewährungsprobe als
strategische reserve des
gesundheitssystems mit auszeichnung
bestanden und ein ganz besonderer dank
gilt vor allem auf anzubieten die das
ganze jahr über denn außer den
ordentlichen zivildienst für die
gesellschaft leisten
aktuell rund 10.500
zivildienstleistenden rund 1700
anerkannten zivildienst einrichtungen im
einsatz für das kommende jahr rechnen
wir wieder mit 14.000 bis 15.000 jungen
männern die im rahmen des zivildienst in
den verschiedenen einrichtungen
entsprechend auch zugewiesen werden
da bereich kranken starken
rettungsdienste altenbetreuung sozial
und behindertenhilfe durch die korona
krise besonders gefordert waren gehen
wir davon aus dass der bedarf der
einrichtungen auch im nächsten jahr
weiter steigen wird das ist ein trend
den wir jetzt schon seit einem jahr noch
erkennen können
und während die bedarfsdeckung 2011 noch
bei rund 90 prozent
97 prozent lag was sie im letzten jahr
nur mehr bei rund 90 prozent
und das zeigt schon hatte sie auf der
einen seite spezielle muss an
gesundheitseinrichtungen eine sehr
großen bedarf an unterstützung haben
aber vor allem eben auch durch die sehr
geburtenschwachen jahrgänge in die
situation kommen dass nicht mehr
genügend zu wählen
eben auch verfügbar waren mit den neuen
tauglichkeitskriterien können wir dieser
entwicklung entgegen halten
das heißt es wird auch einen zivildienst
nach maß gegen das prinzip dass es
künftig tauglichkeitsstufen voll
tauglich und wirklich geben wird wenn
wir damit auch für den zivildienst an
die umsetzung wird eben durch interne
verwaltungsvorschriften auch möglich
werden und ich darf nicht wirklich für
die hervorragende zusammenarbeit mit den
experten des österreichischen
bundesheers bedanken mit denen wir
gemeinsam eben auch diese kriterien
erarbeitet haben
die traurigkeit ist ja bisher schon in
wertungsziel von zwei bis neun
gegliedert es werden nun für deren der
untersten wertungs ziffer 2 durch
geringere aus anforderungen noch
ausgedehnt der ablauf der zuweisung an
die einrichtungen durch die zivildienst
service agentur bleibt aber gleich
das heißt die zuweisung erfolgt
entsprechend bedarf und anforderungen
der einrichtung nach maßgabe der
körperlichen der geistigen der
psychischen fähigkeiten des
zwielichtigen das können auch im
leichter büroarbeiten sein das kann eine
verwaltungsarbeit sein oder eben auch
boten genieße derzeit sind rund 1100
einrichtungen aus den
unterschiedlichsten sparten anerkannt
die anerkennung erfolgt durch den
jeweiligen landeshauptmann eines
bundeslandes
aufgrund der vielfalt ist davon
auszugehen dass es genügend die
lieblingsplätze geben wird um eben auch
auf die jeweiligen einschränkungen des
zivildiensts eingehen zu können
das betrifft beispielsweise den bereich
der administration der jugendarbeit oder
eben auch den it bereich
wir rechnen in zu
damit dass wir rund 800 zusätzliche
zivile richtige durch diese neue teile
teilt aurich kite stufe eben auch
bekommen werden
jeder zivildiener ist mehr als wichtig
und hilft der gesellschaft der gesamten
republik durch seinen dienst und ihr
wissen vor allem auch eines der
zivildienst ist wirklich auch der
türöffner zum ernannt rund ein drittel
der zivildiener bleibenden
organisationen auch nach abgeleisteten
zivildienst in der einen oder anderen
form erhalten leisten damit einen
wirklich unverzichtbaren beitrag für die
gesellschaft indem sie einfach auch
ehrenamtlich weiterhin tätig sein kann
und das war eine auf der ganz besonderen
erfahrungen in den letzten monaten also
wir mit zivilen ausgetauscht habe und
immer gefragt haben warum sie dann
weiterhin beispielsweise eine rotkreuz
einrichtungen als freiwilliger helfer
geblieben sind
dann hat ein junger mann zurück sagt er
findet es gibt im leben eigentlich
nichts schöneres als für jemanden da zu
sein und jemanden zu unterstützen und
ich glaube genau das zeichnet auf unser
land aus das haben wir vor allem heuer
auf im rahmen der korona bande mir
gesehen der zusammenhalt die
solidaritäts in der wichtigste
grundpfeiler unserer gesellschaft mit
der ausweitung eben auch detail
tauglichkeitsstufen schaffen wir so auch
mehr junge männer intensives zu bekommen
und damit eben auch einen beitrag für
unsere gesellschaft zu leisten
vielen herzlichen dank deswegen darf ich
sie um ihre fragen versuchen zu ersuchen
warten bis ich wollte noch nicht nochmal
genauer kommission die sozialdaten sich
800 inneren neue pro jahr
wie schaut das im bereich des
verteidigungsministeriums aus oder
trinken er sich nur zu trainieren
also wir gehen gesamt davon aus dass mit
diesen tauglichkeitsstufen 2000 junge
männer zusätzlich pro jahr sozusagen
tauglichen sein werden und damit
entweder für den grundwehrdienst oder
für den zivildienst zur verfügung stehen
und diese zahl ergibt sich eben haus auf
betrachtungsweise der vergangenheit das
heißt wir rechnen damit 1200 merken wird
ihnen welche rolle wird das bundesheer
oder bei den beiden impfungen spielen
gibt es daneben
pläne und zweiter fall gefordert dass
das bundesheer auch in alters und
pflegeheimen außen bei den testungen
genauso wir haben wenn wir so zum beginn
der korona gesetz früher zurückblicken
sehr viele aufgaben gehabt wie das
bundesheer in der vergangenheit nicht
erfüllt hat wir müssen muss in
unterstützungsleistungen in den lagern
der lebensmittelhändler tätigen oder bei
anderen systemen kritischen bereichen
wie zum beispiel bei der post außer
helfen das hat sich dann gesteigert so
viele tätigkeit nehmen die so zuvor noch
nicht gegeben hat und man hat der gerade
jetzt bei den flächendeckenden tests
gesehen oder man sieht dass wir jetzt
noch bei einem vorweihnachtlichen test
in beinahe allen bundesländern dass das
bundesheer imperialistische
logistikspezialist ist und wenn wir
jetzt an den impfungen denken und eine
vorbereitung dessen dann jetzt auch
hinkünftig und bei dieser frage so sein
dass wir diese besondere logistische
aufgaben erfüllen werden die dazu
notwendig sind das heißt also bei den
impfstoffen angelangt zehnter in
österreich dann wird wenn die
anforderung über die gesundheits
bewerben und wir insbesondere die
logistische notwendigkeit auch für unser
bestehen diese aufgabe zu erfüllen
alles hängt immer mit den anforderungen
eben zusammen die von den
gesundheitsbehörden
bei krones sei es bei der impfung oder
bei den testungen an uns gestellt werden
was die zweiten teil der frage haben
gelangt wir hatten einen einen einsatz
ja schon der auch ein ganz besonderer
waren über geschichte des bundesheeres
ersuchen vorgekommen ist
daher müssen wir zeigen dass wir die
strategische reserve sind in einem
pflegeheim in der in der steiermark
dieser einsatz war notwendig geworden
ist insbesondere der gesamte betrieb
wegen eben dieses pflegeheim es dann
übernommen werden werden musste was man
aber nie vergessen darf wenngleich das
bundesheer die strategische reserve der
republik ist so ist es nach der
verfassung immer nur erlaubt in
assistenz tätig zu werden sei es für die
sicherheitsbehörden oder für die
gesundheitsbehörden alle diese
anforderungen auch bei testungen egal in
welchen welchem bereich oder in welchen
ausmaß haben wir bis dato erfüllen
können und das wird ohne zweifel auch
hinkünftig so seien die originäre
aufgabe des österreichischen
bundesheeres ist das aber schon von der
verfassung nicht das muss auch
klargestellt
so bleibt mir noch mal eine frage zum
zahlen gewusst wie viele gibt es jetzt
die zur erstellung gehen wie viele gibt
es da dieses jahr landen und beim
zivildienst und wieder soll es künftig
geben und eine politische frage
grüne wehrsprecher stögmüller unser
koalitionspartner
gesagt worden ich trete nur dann wenn es
auch verbesserungen religion wird die
wirklich wie sind sie meist mit dem den
grünen abgestimmt und ist das vielleicht
der eigentliche grund dafür dass es nur
über die internen richtlinien machen wir
so gar keine zustimmung der grünen
geworden
vielleicht darf ich mit der dezenten
teil der fragen beginnen
es ist ein projekt das im
regierungsprogramm verankert ist und
dass zum anderen dann eben auch im märz
in einem ministerratsbeschluss in einem
einstimmigen wie sie wissen dann auch
niederschlag gefunden hat man
selbstverständlich dieses unser ziel den
grundwerten sda zu verbessern das zeigt
sich ja schon anhand dessen das wir dass
wir unser dienst nach maß ermöglichen
wollen
was heißt was heißt das viel zu wenig
bekannt ist dass unsere grundwehrdiener
einsatz funktionen bis dato ja schon
tätig sind
das beginnt vom panzer den jäger zum
scharfschützen geht dann weiter zum abc
rettungs und berger gehilfen über cds
nicht alle auch über den elektriker und
so weiter also selbstverständlich sind
diese verbesserungen auch angedacht und
zur frage auch das zur frage in welcher
juristischen art und weise das passiert
es war ja bis dato schon so dass alle
änderungen im vollzug
mit erlass geregelt worden sind das
warten der vergangenheit so
selbstverständlich hat sich aber zu
beginn dieses jahres eine der
arbeitsgruppen waren es gesamten
sicher mit der vergehen wirklichkeit
beschäftigt haben ausschließlich mit den
rechtlichen fragen eben auch beschäftigt
und selbstverständlich werden wir so
machen wie es auch in der vergangenheit
der fall war
mit diesem erlass der im land in kraft
trete mit dem ersten und für die
freundliche recht ein mengengerüst
dessen schon gesagt aber es sind meine
einschätzungen 2000 erwarten wir unser
uns vorzugreifen
bei der konkreten folgen der junge
männer näher und werden die aufteilung
auch hinkünftig dieselbe bleiben wird
von der von der entscheidung her wofür
sich der junge mann entscheidet und
7.800 für den zivildienst 2200 bei uns
vielleicht kann das noch mehr ausführen
der general war
sehr geehrte damen und herren zu ihrer
frage nach den zahlen das jahr 20 19 30
in voller blüte
da haben wir zwar 44.000 stellen
wichtige ehrung beim 30 30.000 tauglich
16.000 haben den größten dienst gemacht
14.000 zivildienst 9300 den 5000 junge
männer konnten da konnte das opfer nicht
abgeschlossen werden wenn es im prinzip
gebrechen gab und bisher stellen
aufgestockt worden
also das sind die zahlen aus dem jahr
2009 10 und man kann annehmen dass es in
den nächsten jahren sich ähnlich
entwickeln wird und was wir versuchen
ist aus den 9000 deutlichen jungen
herren den ethischen auszugeben sowohl
im grundwehrdienst als auch im bsfz
zivildienst für die republik österreich
dienst zu tun
fast den ganzen winter plädiert nach
frankreich das heißt welche eingangs
erwähnt haben den 4
wenn einmal ein drittel wenn man da
jetzt von den 9000 2000 sie die tat
bringt das wie weit man darunter
prozentuell gesehen also wie viel
prozent werden dann täglich sein und
darauf an an die von christine mit
welcher bedarfsdeckung reschensee das
geht sich dann aus essen das ist ein
prozent wie schon zuletzt geschehen wird
das ganze nacht haben uns zu setzen
prozentuell besetzt sind ja im kopf
nicht ausgerechnet bei uns ganz 1200 die
der zusätzlichen die organisation
bekommen und für diese 1200 die
zusätzlich der organisation zu das
bisher zur verfügung stehen können wir
menschen die junge ehren die fünf bis
neun tage sind es sinnvoll deutlich
anspruchsvollere einsatz funktionen
bringen das ist unser ziel so dass wir
die einsatzverbände stärken und die
eltern unterstützung sorgte mit dem
lernen verstärken die zusätzlich vom
montag
unser system von uns gebracht werden
prozentuell also wir haben derzeit etwa
30 prozent
tägliche werden dann wahrscheinlich 25
prozent ist es dann sozusagen ein großer
wurf ist dass das was sie sich
vorgestellt haben also von wenn man nur
vom 30 vielleicht vielleicht um eine
sinn in einer relation zu setzen wenn es
uns gewünscht hätten diese 2000
zusätzlichen männern für den
grundwehrdienst beziehungsweise für den
zivildienst zu gewinnen wenn man sich
alleine die notwendigkeiten anschaut die
im vergangenen jahr schon daran jeder
einzelne der sozusagen ein zusätzlich
generiert werden kann ist ja ein ganz
ein großer ein großer schritt dass das
muss man an dieser stelle schon sagen
von diesem gefühl hat man pro jahr die
zustellung kommen und da jetzt noch
einmal 2000 dazu zu bekommen und
natürlich wird auch jeder eine
anstrengung übernehmen den dienst bei
uns ist eben der grundwehrdienst also so
schmackhaft auch wie möglich zu machen
damit es eben mehr sind die sich für den
grundwehrdienst entscheidendes
wird minister köstinger wurden die
einzelnen organisationen dann auch tun
also das ist schon ein sehr großer
schritt für jeden einzelnen aber auch
für die gesamte gesellschaft
also ich kann mich dem nur anschließen
wenn sie will es kommt hinzu dass ihr
die bildungseinrichtungen den bedarf
anmelden und das war in den letzten 10
jahren durchaus auch schwanken
wir rechnen damit dass in den nächsten
jahren der bedarf steigen wird
spezielle eben auch dass das durch das
immer älter werdende bevölkerung ist
vollkommen klar dass es hier mehr
betreuungseinrichtungen mehr
pflegeeinrichtungen auch braucht wir
sind wirklich sehr gut in abstimmung mit
den landeshauptleuten der vor allem auch
für die anerkennung der zivis
einrichtungen zuständig sind
wir rechnen ungefähr mit einer
steigerung der bedarfsdeckung von fünf
bis sechs prozent
dort hilft das selbe die auch für das
österreichische bundesheer jeder
einzelne civil in unserem fall wird
wirklich dringend benötigt und verstärkt
eben auch das gesundheitssystem und
deswegen eben auch dieser schritt jetzt
in die traurigkeit
löffel berge von atv 2 tagen abseits von
pinien sind bisher in frankreich sehr
hätte ich natürlich dass ein barren
energie zu seiner erneuten
ausschreitungen die zwei masten ist für
den geschäften ist nicht ändern erklärt
regeln also bewusst wahr denn anders
sein als bei den rest was hinter diesem
aufschlagen kann das auch verstehen also
nachdem sie dann eine zivildienst und
bundesheer pressekonferenz steht ihnen
im anschluss sehr gerne für andere
fragen zur verfügung
noch mehr allein auf die talent her
gehört
die tore werden steinstufen mit youtube
reden oder stufe 2 mittel besser und
habe ich das richtig
und das klingt dann eben irgendwie mal
den stimmen der solisten wünsche dir
nochmals die notwendigkeit anders da
kurz sozusagen der technische teil der
beantwortung ihrer frage wir haben drei
stützen und örtlich vorübergehend und
auch ich nicht ob ich nun endlich 2 und
was wird gemacht haben nach dem großen
gamesmarkt macht aus dem die
vorkommnisse
bereits angesprochen hatten haben wir
sowieso die mars gesteuert er als in der
vergangenheit versucht funktion in
verbindung mit einer ausbildungs
notwendigkeit zu verbinden und diese
maßstab erfüllt jetzt dazu dass wir für
bestimmte kunden für bestimmte
funktionen einfach eine weniger
herausfordernde ausbildung anbieten
können und das führt dazu dass wir in
der lage sind mehr jungen sowohl für der
gruppe dienst als auch für den
wehrersatzdienst etc videos zu gewinnen
und ich es bekommt wie man das prädikat
eindeutig die franzosen ist ein künstler
in ihren gesperrten bekommen von uns wie
bisher die informationen übermitteln und
bekommen auch so wie bisher die
vollumfänglich informationen immer die
fähigkeit
ebenso dass die experten der
bundesministerin die jungen sänger
entsprechend einsetzen
sie sind wir ein bisschen aus wie
wichtig der grünen oder dem grundstück
grünen eigentlich noch bedingungen
durchzubringen
ist das für sie etwas was man einfach so
beiseite wischen kann ist das etwas das
gemeinsame das gibt es einen
ministerbeschluss oder was ist ein
standard also ich glaube wenn keine ein
gemeinsames ziel im regierungsprogramm
auf formuliert ist dann auch beschlossen
worden ist
vor geraumer zeit im frühjahr in mercks
und dann eine vorgehensweise auch
gewählt wird wie in der vergangenheit
auch immer der fall war was dem vollzug
anbelangt nämlich dies mit erlass zu
regeln und das gemeinsame ziel auch ganz
klar formuliert ist dann ist da
überhaupt keiner leider keinerlei
unterschied auch zu sehen es wurde sehr
lange und intensiv daran gearbeitet an
diesem gemeinsamen ziel und ab dem
ersten er
geht es an die umsetzung alex getragen
eine dieser vor einer dieser wünschen
von grüner seite war auf das nahm er als
die von werten und auch finanziell
besser gestellt werden können sie das in
aussicht stellen dass wir in jedem fall
gemacht gemacht haben ist dass wir den
grundwehrdienern eine möglichkeit bieten
die ja eine eine durchaus interessante
aus auch ist mit mein dienst für
österreich wurde der nationalfeiertag
gegen eine floristin machen die größte
aufwertung des grundwehrdienstes
kommuniziert das heißt wenn sich die
grundwehrdiener melden zur medizin
wahrheit nur zu 30 übungstagen verteilt
auf zehn jahre
dann können sie ab dem dritten monat
bereits 400 euro monatlich zusätzlich zu
ihrem bekommen in wahrheit ist das ja
dann eine
doppelungen eigentliche besoldung unter
die weitere möglichkeit ist dann auch
noch dass man wenn sich der wert
wichtige zur miliz gemeldet hat dann ja
auch schon den ersten teil der
kommandanten ausbildung absolvieren kann
und das heißt dann noch einmal monatlich
weitere 200 millionen euro dazu also
tatsächlich die grösste aufwertung des
grundwehrdienstes die wir mit dieser
dieser mit diesen möglichkeiten dann
auch schaffen und ein um eine dritte
auch nicht unerwähnt zu lassen es gibt
es sehr viele junge männer das besondere
auch eine zeitung überbrücken haben
nämlich die zeitraum zwischen dem
grundwehrdienst unter dem studium oder
den beruf start und auch diese
möglichkeit bieten wir dass diese zeit
im sinnvoll auch genutzt werden kann nur
so kann man dann eine dreimonatige
assistenzeinsatz auch bewältigen
indirekter nach dem grund wird im sind
auch da ist ein sehr großes große auch
finanzieller anreiz mit der richtige der
das ja bitte aber keine generellen
generell das ändern ein wichtiger punkt
worauf dieses programm ab insbesondere
auf die individualität auf ein schaffen
des grundwehrdienstes oder auch eben des
ersatzdienstes für den jeweiligen jungen
mann entsprechend seiner fähigkeiten
körperlichen und psychischen bereich ja
das ist das ist eben der große vorteil
neben der anzahl an jungen männer fünf
sätze gewinnen können und wenn ich
einfach den wert filtern darf wieder
hoffen gelegenheit benutzen sie der
hitze laden zu unserer virtuellen
weihnachtsfeier 18 uhr die auf youtube
übertragen wird er sagen